technoblade a youtuber known for his
minecraft streams has died he lost his
battle with cancer at just 23 years old
[Music]
yo technoblade here with another upload
oh my god i can't believe it we're back
we're playing bedwars the gamer's father
confirmed his death in a video posted to
technoblade's youtube channel i'm
technoblade's dad
he wrote a message and he asked me to
read it to all of you
hello everyone technoblade here
if you're watching this
i'm dead technoblade's dad goes on to
share more of his son's message thank
you all for supporting my content over
the years
if i had another hundred lives i think i
would choose to be technoblade again
every single time
as those were the happiest years of my
life technoblade whose real name was
alex shared his cancer diagnosis with
his followers last august i looked at
myself in the mirror and i noticed that
my right shoulder was starting to swell
like crazy and i was like oh my god
i must have broken a bone this is i mean
this it looked crazy so you know the
next day august 2nd i headed over to the
doctor to see what was wrong and uh they
they ran a couple of scans and then they
came back and they told me that uh the
reason my arm hurts is because i have
cancer and now tributes are pouring in
from the gaming community nate allen
gets emotional sharing his story of how
technoblade encouraged him to keep
streaming i never tell this story but
i was really considering
i was really considering quitting all of
this
and
this potato war videos
they really
i know it sounds dumb but they really
help me
i've never seen anyone put so much
dedication into their craft before
another gamer stopped her stream early
because she couldn't believe the news
thank you to all of you
for everything
[Music]
you meant a lot to him and technoblade's
dad finished his message by sharing his
love for his son
he was the most amazing
[Music]
he was the most amazing kid anyone could
ever ask for
i miss technoblade
you